who your good I can't
focus no don't step in
the hi I'm ning hi I'm jaelle hi I'm
Karina hi I'm winter and we are Esa and
we're here with BuzzFeed and we're going
to be playing with
puppies what's up we can't
wait where is my
baby what
oh my God you
[Music]
guys oh she's peeing have your moment
baby
come here
puppies come here come here you're so
[Laughter]
[Music]
kind oh bless you
i w to be a
bird so you can fly yes and free I want
to be a cat I'd be a cat as
[Music]
well love
yourself don't be
stupid
more have fun have more
fun use your time
wisely welcome to my world mice my navis
we love you my puppy is so
cute there is nothing as peaceful
and drop the puppy I was going to say
there's nothing as peaceful in healing
as little
puppies you just got to be born with no
but I actually I wasn't really
interested in in skincare for like a
really for like my whole life but the
tours actually got me interested in it
and I would go to like if it's La I'd go
to like Sephora and just like buy
skincare wherever I go like just because
it's fun for me experiment see what's
best for you and get a routine for
yourself everyone's different
[Music]
so that's my favorite the recent one
that I saw is called blood hounds that
was super super
[Music]
fun by
[Laughter]
Red who would you like to see us collab
with answer in the
comments
[Music]
honestly I'm open to any genre but
something that I would personally like
to try is action like Tomb Raider
yeah oh genius and
oh she's
[Applause]
genius sometime I play Tetris baby you
and me are fantasy oh my God the pose is
like okay yes pretty yeah it's like
apple juice it's like mango mango wow
cute no don't step in the
[Laughter]
PE oh it smells like te
[Music]
Spirit uh it's really depends and when I
feel down if I want to sit on the mood I
just listen to the set song but if I
want be more happier uh I love techno or
something arm be like something chill to
make me feel better
yeah
[Music]
I have winter
as and Karina as I don't know why I
still have you as Kem
Dusty ning ning oh you can't say that I
know I can't it's a secret it's a secret
y'all are never going to know well and
then
[Music]
Ed I can
[Applause]
say
I like smelling
rice like just just white rice like
right when it's cooked like smelling it
I'm just weird like that but
yeah
Evolution Evolution
[Music]
human on my left hand puppy is Cookie
because he is eating my
hand right hand puppy Sloop
dog
[Music]
I'll name him Travis Travis because
shout out to Travis
Barker I will name him brown
brown bre BR his name is
BR can I take him home do you
mind
no happy happy n happy n happy Travis
don't
bite actually we've done this before but
not like this genre is we did a remake
of Dreams Come True one of my favorite
songs actually by us is dreams come true
and I think I like the whole old Vibe
and I think it would be so cool since
I'm a huge Rock fan to be able to do
like a old rock remake or something like
[Music]
that oh we look at each other and smile
and
laugh with our dancers we always do can
you recreate it right now yeah yeah oh
my my baby's sleeping
[Music]
no Dina AA she's this rapper singer
fashionista Rising Star I don't know I
just love her music and I found her on
Tik Tok and I think she would be great
with these puppies
[Music]
oh dog absolutely
dog baby I'm sorry cat
no his sleeping no no
no oh
cat
cat oh sorry sorry sorry but I love you
we're going to do the outro
no you
can if you want to adopt these puppies
adop this puppies if you want to adopt
adopt this puppies adopt this
puppy if you want to adopt this puppies
you can find them on pop culture
rescue thanks bus and don't forget to
check out our new song better things out
now I wish I could take you
[Music]
home
no
[Music]